three weeks after the Paris attacks and
subsequent claims of poor information
sharing mepz advanced legislation to
strengthen the Mandate of Europol the EU
police force making it easier for it to
set up terrorists pulse units and share
information with private and
non-government bodies Mbps on the civil
liberties committee endorsed the
proposal on Monday los Estados membros
tendrán muchas ma capacidad apsara
interconnect arcona global euro Poulton
dramas potencia para cumplir con las
obligaciones que tienes talathi earth
another tool in the same fight against
terrorism the passenger name record
directive governing the use of air
passengers data one issue at stake how
long data should be kept and in what
form mask or unmasked identity shown or
hidden on Tuesday the civil liberties
committee got an update on talks with
member states from the mep leading them
and confident that we will get a good
agreement by the end of this year
Christianity the world's most populous
religion whose minorities are also its
most persecuted em eps were joined by
faith leaders on tuesday to discuss how
to protect these minorities in the
Middle East in the Far East and Africa
from the imprisonment torture banishment
and discrimination they face a shrewd
skilled nice pure the iana order the
unliving yawns again for a lousy give
give now so focus on wednesday em eps
voted to extend the life of parliament
special committee on tax rulings by six
months it was set up in February to
investigate the lowering of
multinationals tax bills in some Member
States any peace want extra time to dig
out documents they've so far been denied
make take de spokes three words at the
heart of the consumer driven economy but
how about reuse repair and recycle three
words at the heart of the circular
economy designed to reduce waste and
save rare resources European Commission
presented its revamped circular economy
package on Wednesday it was broadly
welcomed by M EPS but with complaints
that the proposals on waste recycling
and reducing landfill went nearly
ambitious enough the same day a crucial
debate on the e use recent summit with
Turkey to stem the flow of migrants
across its territory from the conflicts
in Iraq and Syria Ankara is being
offered three billion euros to help but
say some mep s the money can't be
unconditional in a written conclusions
nothing was said about human rights in
Turkey freedom of press in Turkey state
of democracy in Turkey that's the
failure of this summit in my opinion